Men have called me mad.
But the question is not yet settled, whether madness is or is not
the loftiest intelligence.
Whether much that is glorious, whether all that is profound
does not spring from a disease of thought.
Madness is terrific I can assure you
not to be sniffed at
How sad is it
Insanity to the sane seems so unnecessary
Madness
the sublimity of all intelligence
backward at people who are now dead
and confidently say
that they suffered from madness of some order
that no greater stigma still exists
than mental illness
and here you are
Nash the mathematician
Well I think
and the
those areas of the brain thought to be involved in
helping create
Psychologists to accept is that you could
incur brain damage and end up better off
after the brain damage
and this could happen in a number of systems
and so one of the systems involved is the frontal lobe
all of the sudden they have never been creative then all of the sudden they become creative
and something seems to be released so these areas of the frontal lobe
are thought to be involved
not only and you can see here
this is just for bipolar
those areas in red
the upper parts of the brain tend to be turned off in people with bipolar
where as the areas in blue
down below
are the things that are always turned on
and they have a lot to do with negative affect
and stress
and these all turned off dopamine,
dopamine makes you feel good
and in the case of depression it turns it off
in taking both the kind of neuro anatomy
of depression
and the neuro anatomy of what we know so far of creativity
and we put  of them together in the next slide
my own pathology I'm absolutely mad about pictures
so the interaction of bipolar disorder in creativity you can see those areas
are also the areas that interact
so-called creativity circuits and you can see here
positively associated with mood
and creativity
and the switching to the blue position
switching back and forth
is thought to have a lot to do with bipolar
but also swings in creativity like we heard
people are only creative like  bipolars are only creative when they're coming out of it
but what they're getting down there
that deep water that people don't want to go to
is something the rest of us can't access
the way it's expressed when these upper areas are turned on
I was really surprised
when I put these together that there was this nexus
between these circuits
probably as many roads to creativity to
I think it will be fair to say that depression is mostly associated with
creative
not actually no
about a year ago
showing that in fact
primary associations with bipolar illness